so right here I have the garden tower
and I'm going to assemble it and what it
is is a tower compact tower that you can
grow up to 50 little plants and I plan
on putting some strawberries the other
nice feature about this is that you can
put food scraps in the middle of it and
the plants will eat it and so I put it
here on my deck where it's close to the
kitchen so we can just easily put food
scraps in it so let's get started
[Music]
so I don't quite have enough dirt to
fill this up but I'm eager to get some
plants in there so I'm going to go ahead
and plant the strawberries that I have
so the instructions say that fill it up
about a third of the way the soil and
then add approximately three gallons of
water to the soil that's there and I'll
just circle this
so I've given the water a chance to
percolate down now I'm going to get
these strawberries out these are pine
Barry White Carolina strawberries and
then there's some red ones in here as
well to help with the pollination end up
with purposing feedbags in order to fill
up with some topsoil from the high
tunnel project
[Music]
and the idea is that over time this
water and stuff will come down here
would be the nutria team so then you can
take this bring it back up here
[Music]
poor back in there
so I'll go ahead and let it go let it
get situated before I plant anything
else in the top but I'm really thrilled
to try this out now I these are
available on farmer Broadcom and I've
purchased this one with my own money
because I wanted to be able to try it
out firsthand
and so these two rows are going to be
strawberries and what I like about this
is that you can rotate it around and so
if you have like a small amount of space
you got 50 opportunities to grow
something which i think is incredible
now they do offer an upgrade kit where
you can get coaster or wheels for the
three legs that way it can be moved
around a little bit but I have it on my
deck so that's close to the kitchen so
it can put food scraps in there and this
way is south facing so it should get
plenty of Sun throughout the day no
matter which side the plants are on so
thanks for watching I hope you enjoyed
this video and make sure to get your the
garden tower project to farmer Brad calm